- Ryan, I have a question.
(audience applauding)
You and Blake are expecting.
(audience cheers)
(laughing)
- Oh, my God!
You know? You knew.
- This is how I find out!?
Yes, yes, we are; we are.
- How are you preparing for this new baby?
- God, well, the first one, you know-
(audience oohs and ahhs)
- [Host] It is sweet.
- The first one you get,
everything's, like, perfect
and you just set everything up just right.
Just everything's sterilized.
But by the fourth, you're
just like, "Oh, right.
"This is happening.
(guests laughing)
"I should sweep or something."
- Just like in the calendar, yeah.
- So, not as much
preparation is happening.
Now, I shouldn't speak for my wife
because, yeah, she's in
it to win it right now.
She's ready.
And we're very excited, though.
- [Host] That is exciting.
- We're very excited, yeah.
- A little extra help around the house
is why I'm in it.
- That's good.
- Yeah, yeah.